safe to say it's more than just about
der eat a dog and a blog 100% way more
than that I hope so god I hope so
absolutely not it's an it's a very long
season - so this is jam-packed it's also
about people coming together and really
developing friendships which i think is
very cool really we're gonna blow your
can - The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills serving up their best season nine
teases after their epic season premiere
she would never say that about you maybe
you care more about your image than your
friendships
having to rewatch that what went through
your head
setting it was upsetting in the moment
setting to watch it's very difficult you
know I care about both Lisa and Ken and
I never imagined it would get to that
point and it's unfortunate and I hope
that one day it can be resolved I
haven't seen the episode I chose not to
watch personally it was a very difficult
time in my life so I've chosen not to go
back to that space you know not to watch
it Vanderpump a sniper from the side
this year I said it the first time hey
listen I already said what I had to say
everyone else can pick up where I left
off well we all know Vanderpump in the
group essentially part ways midseason
I love you how can you say you loved me
all right she chose the tag line yeah
you could stab me in the back but lost
you're there kiss my ass is that pointed
at anybody in particular just how I was
feeling you know it's I think the the
tagline should reflect your feelings of
the season so that's what I wanted to
say and of course sometimes Bravo's say
oh you sure about that yes I'm really
sure I'm not afraid of hard work but
I'll never do your dirty work was that
directed at no you're gonna have to tune
in to see yeah I'm sure you can make
your own assumptions but that's all I
can say about that and the ladies say
there are way more surprises in store
it's two seasons in one by the way it's
two seasons in one maybe that's how I
describe it it's two seasons in one the
changes are so extreme and you just
don't know what to expect and you're
just it's kind of lap one thing after
another it surprised me every day I was
actually surprised every single day I
had
I I am saying I don't have any words
because every day I was like I didn't
know what was gonna happen next and it
doesn't come good to live life like that
but you'll see some friendships come
together that you didn't quite think and
you'll see some friendships break in a
way that you didn't think they would
then of course there's a new girl in
town timing was right and if I'm gonna
do a show like this I would want to be
my true authentic self and be really
honest and open and I'm in a great place
to do that and so I thought why not and
just have fun with it I had a lot of fun
I really did
keep the friends close your enemies
closer have you had to sum up this
season with just one word what's your
word for the season crazy it's just I
mean there's so many words I can't there
so many ups and downs it's unbelievable
there's so many words deceitful
difficult emotional trying to laugh we
have fun it's a little mix of everything
but it's a crazy season but
[Music]